[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره الخامسه
يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر ونستهلها بابرز
العناوين
[موسيقى]
يتهموا واشنطن واوروبا باعاقه محادثات
السلام بشان اوكرانيا والاخيره تحذر من
وقف اطلاق النار
ترقب لمصير ترامب بعد مزام اعتقاله اليوم
وتاهب امني واسع خوفا من تكرار سيناريو
الكابيتون
الخزانه الامريكيه تتعهد باجراءات لحمايه
الودائع لو زادت عدوى سحب الاموال بعد
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
ف افغانستان المدارس تفتح ابوابها في
العام الدراسي الجديد بدون فتيات مع
استمرار حظر طالبان لتعليمهن
البدايه من موسكو حيث استقبل الرئيس
الروسي النظيره الصيني
فيزا ببدء المحادثات الرسميه بين الرئيسين
وكان الكرملين اشار في وقت سابق الى
في اليوم الاول الخطه الصينيه للسلامه في
اوكرانيا دون الخوض في التفاصيل وقد اكد
الرئيس الصيني انا بكين ستواصل العمل على
جعل العلاقات مع روسيا على راس اولوياتها
وعلى وقع الوساطه الصينيه اتهم المتحدث
باسم الكليمن او الكرملين دي الولايات
المتحده والدول الاوروبيه بالوقوف عائقا
امام اي محادثات سلام بشان اوكرانيا وقال
بيسكوف ان الدول الغربيه تمنع كيف من
التفكير في اي محادثات سلام محتمله
هذا واكد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
وانج وان بينج ان الرئيس الصيني يؤكد ان
هناك اصواتا اكثر سلميه وعقلانيه وان معظم
الدول تؤيد تخفيف حده التوتر في اوكرانيا
وتدعو الى تشجيع المفاوضات والمحادثات
السلميه
فيما يخص القضيه الاوكرانيه اكد الرئيس
شيشي جين بينك ان هناك اصواتا اكثر سلميه
وعقلانيه معظم الدول تؤيد تخفيف حده
التوتر وتدعو الى تشجيع المفاوضات
والمحادثه السلميه وتعارض صب الزيت على
النار تاريخيا حل النزاعات يتطلب الحوار
والتفاوض في النهايه منذ وقت غير بعيد
اصدرت الصين ورقه الموقف بشان القضيه
الاوكرانيه داعيه الى حل سياسي للازمه
وعلى وقع الوساطه الصيني حذرت كياب من
امكانيه القبول بوقف اطلاق النار مع روسيا
وقال ميخائيل بودلاك المستشار بالرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان اي محاوله لتجويد الصراع مع
روسيا واطاله امده تعني حربا لا تنتهي في
قلب اوروبا واضاف المسؤول الاوكراني في
حسابه على تويتر بان ذلك سيؤدي الى
التقويض اسس الامن العالمي
وتنضم الينا من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا اهلا بك كاتيا هل بدا الاجتماع بين
الجانبين الروسي والصيني على مستوى
الرؤساء والوفود سياسيا
[موسيقى]
توقيع الجانبين الروسي والصيني في نهايه
هذه اللقاءات على نحو عشر وثائق من بينها
وثيقتين رئيسيتين الوثيقه الاولى هي وثيقه
عميق للتعاون الاستراتيجي بين البلدين
والوثيقه الثانيه هي
تعميق التعاون الاقتصادي بين البلدين طبعا
الذي طبعا نشهده والذي يزدهر بايام
الاخيره بعد طبعا ما تم فرض العقوبات على
روسيا حيث كما تحدثت شركه اليوم هناك
زياده كبيره في داخل غاز الروسي الى الصين
الى نحو خمسه عشرة ونصف مليار متر مكعب
كما تحدثت اليوم الشركه في بيان لها يعني
الى اي مدى تعول موسكو على هذه الزياره
الانفتاح على الصين الاقتصاد ربما ثاني
اكبر اقتصاد في العالم اقتصاديا وايضا
سياسيا والى اي مدى هناك حيز للملف
الاوكراني اليوم في هذه المحادثات بال امس
كان هناك حديث عن مبادره صينيه اليوم هل
هناك اي مكان او نتوقع تصريحات من
الزعيمين حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
بالفعل ابراهيم هناك نقطتين رئيسيتين
تتعاون عليهم عليهما روسيا خلال هذه
الزياره التي كما قيمها الخبراء هي
مهمه جدا بالنسبه لروسيا بظل العقوبات
التي تم فرضها من قبل الغرب على روسيا
ومحاوله عزلها اقتصاديا هي تشكل طبعا بابا
يفتح لروسيا اقتصاديا على عالم اخر ومن
خلال الصين الصين البلد
القوي استراتيجيا واقتصاديا اما سياسيا
ايضا الشريك الدائم سياسيا لروسيا والتي
كانت كما تحدث بعض الخبراء ايضا دور الصين
كبير في عمليه اعاده العلاقات بين
السعوديه
وايران لذلك هناك تعويل ايضا على امكانيه
حل الازمه الاوكرانيه وبالخلال الطرح الذي
طرحته الصين خلال الخطه السلام الذي تحدثت
عنها والتي تالف من 12 بندا كانت قد تم
بحثها كما قال الكريم بشكل موسع يوم امس
خلال اللقاء
والذي قيمه ايضا ورحب به الرئيس الروسي
رحب بهذا بهذا الطرح والخطه
الصينيه لذلك كما تحدث المتحدث الرسمي
باسم
هناك توقعات بان يتطرق الرئيسي خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي سنشده بعد نحو ساعه
ساعه لتقييم الى لهذه الخطه من كل الجانب
الروسي ومن الجانب الصيني
خلال وبعد هذا المؤتمر انا اشكرك على كل
هذه المعلومات مراسله العربيه كنت معنا
مباشره من موسكو
اعلنا حاكم او وصل اليوم رئيس الوزراء
الياباني في يوميا
في زياره مفاجئه هي الاولى له منذ بدء
الحرب وافاد التلفزيون الياباني انا
كيشيدا شوهد وهو ينزل من قطار في محطه
بوسط كييف حيث سيلتقي الرئيس الاوكرانيه
رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا جورج ياميلوني اكدت
ان روما ستستمر بدعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه
روسيا بغض النظر عن نسبه الموافقه
الحكوميه على قرارات دعم كييف وقالت بلوني
في كلمه لها امام مجلس الشيوخ قبل
الاجتماع المرتقب للمجلس الاوروبي قالت ان
ايطاليا ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا رغم
التاثيرات قصيره المدى لهذه القرارات على
الحكومه
ميدانيا شدد قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه
على ان الدفاع عن مدينه باق موت مستمر
اضاف في بيان اللاهوب بان القوات
الاوكرانيه وجهت ضربات قويه لمواقع قوات
الروسيه والجماعات المتحالفه معها في شملت
مخازن اسلحه ولفت ان هذه الضربات اسهمت في
وقف تقدمها في ضواحي بخموت الى مركز
المدينه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نتحول مباشره الى الولايات
المتحده لمتابعه تصريحات وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه حول الازمه المصارف الاخيره
البنوك الكبيره لها دور مهم في اقتصادنا
وكذلك الصغيره والمتوسطه لكن هذه المصارف
عملت
بمهام
الصيرفه التقليديه في تقديم الدعم
والمساعده للاسر وللمشاريع الصغيره كما هي
تعمل على زياده المشاركه في القطاع
المصرفي وهناك
خبره في هذه المجتمعات التي يستثمرون بها
لكن كثير من هذه البنوك تقوم بدور مهم في
دعم الانتعاش الاقتصادي في وسط الازمه
التي كانت بسبب الجائحه وكانت الخزانه
قادره على الاستجابه لكل من يحتاج
المساعده عملنا انكتب معكم
لارسال الدفعات لملايين الاسر وعملتم معنا
لايصال
المسبقه
للائتمان الرعايه رعايه الطفوله اللي
العمل على خفض الفقر بين الاطفال وكذلك
نشر المساعده لمئات الالاف من اصحاب
المنازل الذين يعانون من
التعرض
فقداني بيوتهم بسبب القرود وتعثرها
وبالتالي هناك ايضا مبادرات وقبل هذا
البرنامج
كان هناك عشر مليار دولار من الاصول
مسؤوله عن 95% من البرامج او القروض
المدعومه من هذا البرنامج وادارتنا كانت
تركز على
مصارف
تعمل على
نمو اقتصادي شامل فعلى سبيل المثال
الخزانه والاستثمارات
استثمرات ثلاثه فاصل 4 مليار دولار من منح
ومساعدات
ودعما للشركات
خزانه كانت تعمل على
تاكد
لتنافسيه مجتمعنا المصرفي الحيوي ومؤسساته
لذلك في الخاتمه
دعوني اعود لما بدات بهم
النظام المصرفي الامن هو
دليل على الصحه الاقتصاد الامريكي ونحن
نقوم
بمهمتنا وتاكدوا اننا سنبقى حذرين
وساعمل على المضي بالتعاون لدعم نظامنا
المصرفي واقتصادي امتنا شكرا لكم
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا جانبا من كلمه وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانتي تحدثت عن جهود
الخزانه الامريكيه لاحتواء الازمه الحاليه
وايضا الازمات السابقه خصوصا ازمه 2008
وقالت بان هناك حاجه لاعاده مراجعه نظام
الرقابه المصرفيه على كل حال نتابع بهذا
الشان حيث كانت اعلنت الوزيره على ان
استقرار القطاع المصرف الامريكيه بعد
الاخفاقات الاخيره ممكن واوضحت بان التدخل
خزانه الامريكيه كانت ضرووريا لحمايه
النظام مصرفي الاوسع وتعهدت باتخاذ
اجراءات مماثله اذ عانت المؤسسات الاصغر
من عمليات ايداع تشكل خطر انتقال العدوى
المصرفيه مؤكده ان تدفقات الودائع
الخارجيه من البنوك الاقليميه شهدت
استقرارا
وانضم الينا من دبي المحلل الصادي احمد
الخطيب اهلا بك سيد احمد لا ادري اذا كنت
تابعت تصريحات
كنا تحدثنا قبل ذلك قبل الهواء وقلت لي
بانه كلما خرج مسؤول وتحدث عن هذه الازمه
عزز المخاوف اكثر لو توضح لنا هذه النقطه
تحديدا
نعم يعني كل ما عم بيكون في جهات رقبيه او
سلطات او حتى الحكومات اللي عم تخرج عم
بتقول انه بدنا نطمئن سنقوم باجراءات هذا
يعني يوضح الخوف من انه تفاقم الازمه الى
حد لا يكون السيطره عليك حتى الان
الاجراءات التي قامت بها سلطات مختلفه في
عده دول خصوصا في امريكا وفي سويسرا كانت
يعني سريعه وفعاله ويعني منع التفاقم
الاضرار او انتقال العدوى بشكل سريع رغم
انه عم نشوف بعض التخوف الاسواق انا برايي
انه يعني لحتى نحس انه فعلا تم السيطره
على الازمه الاستقرار بدها تخف نبره
التطمينات لانه حتى يكون فعلا صار في
اطمئنان بالاسواق اكثر من انه بحاجه الى
كلام او تصريحات او اجراءات جديده لحتى
تطمئن الاسواق برايك انه الفيدرالي
الامريكي سيذهب الى مزيد من الرفع لاسعار
الفائده ام ماذا كيف تتوقع ان تخرج نتائج
اجتماعاته اليوم وغدا
يعني
يعني اخر شيء كان بده اياه انه يكون عنده
الازمه الحاليه بخضام كل الاشياء اللي عم
بيعاني منها
بمكافحه تضخم رفع الفائده هلا اعتقد من
الصعب صار انه يستمر بالرفع العالي اللي
كان متوقع مثلا عن نصف نقطه وايضا انا
اعتقد يعني في سياق اللي كنا عم نحكيه قبل
شوي انه اذا لم يرفع الفائده نهائيا اعتقد
قد يفهم منها انه الفيدرالي يرى ان الازمه
كبيره جدا ولذلك انه يختار عدم رفع
الفائده لذلك انا ارجح يعني انه يكون هناك
رفع بربع نقطه يعني انه يستمر في سياسته
في مكافحه التضخم لانه الفيدرالي بالنهايه
يعني يهم الاستقرار الاوضاع بالكامل ما
هامه فقط التضخم ويدمر قطاع البنكي يعني
عليه يوازن بين الامور هذه الازمه ستذهب
الى
انفراج ام مزيد من التعقيد باقل من نصف
دقيقه اذا سمحت
والله يعني يعتمد يعني انا مثل ما عم بقول
انه تختلف عن ازمه 2008 اللي كان فيها
يعني
مشاكل في البنوك هون عم نشوف الوزن الاكبر
للثقه اذا تم السيطره على هذا الموضوع
بدون ظهور مفاجات جديده في الايام القادمه
اعتقد انه ممكن ولكن يعني نتمنى ان لا
تحصل شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا المحلل
الصادي احمد الخطيب كنت معنا مباشره من
دبي
ما ان تم الاعلان عن انهيار ثلاثه بنوك
امريكيه في اسبوع واحد وتشكيلها لاول ازمه
ماليه بهذا الحجم منذ العام 2008 بدات
اصابع الاتهام تتجه نحو من قد يكون
المتسبب بهذه الازمه بعض الخبراء رمي
المسؤوليه على الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي وقراراته المتاخره بمعالجه
الازمات فبعد اتهامات للاحتياطي الفيدرالي
بانه تاخر كثيرا في تدارك ازمه ارتفاع
التضخم بعدم رفعه لاسعار الفائده بوتيره
سريعه اظهرت ازمه البنوك المنهاره ثغره
كبيره في مهام الفيدرالي واهمها الرقابه
على البنوك
فقبل اكثر من عام من سقوط بنك اس في بي
عين الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في سان فرانسيسكو
فريقا لمعينه اصول البنك واطلق الفريق
المتخصص انذارات عده ومطالب باصلاحات هامه
في بنك
وبنهايه العام الماضي طالب الفريق
باصلاحات شامله لمواجهه مخاطره ارتفاع
الفائده واثرها على ميزانيه البنك من جهه
اخرى جاءت تنظيمات القطاع المالي في عهد
الرئيس السابق ترامب والتي خففت قيود
الافصاح على البنوك التي تتجاوز اصولها
250 مليار دولار عاملا اخر في ازمه سقوط
البنوك الثلاثه خاصه بعد اعفائها من بعض
القيود على راس المال المتوفر لديها
واستثنائها من اختبارات فحص جهد المالي
وفي تطور لافت وفي اواخر العام 2021
تعيين نائب رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في
سان فرانسيسكو جريجوري والمسؤول عن رقابه
بنك اس بي بي انذاك لاستلام مهمه اخرى تم
مثلت بان يكون المسؤول عن الجهه التنظيميه
في بنك سيلفر غيت الذي تعثر هذا الشهر
ايضا بيكر الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك اس بي بي
قام قبل اسبوعين من سقوط البنك ببيع اسهم
في البنك بثلاثه ملايين
دولار وهو يخضع حاليا لتحقيق من وزاره
العدل لقيامه بذلك
تماسك البنكي بسندات قديمه ذات عائد منخفض
جدا لوقت الاستحقاق مقابل فوائد اكبر
يدفعها على ودائع العملاء كان كفيلا بسقوط
مدن اشعله اندفاع العملاء لسحب ودائعهم من
البنك
شادي الزعيم العربيه
الخامسه مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
اخوك
الكنيست يلغي قانون فك الارتباط ويسمح
بعوده الاسرائيليين لمستوطنات بالضفه
الغربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد دانام الى موسكو نتوجه
الى كلمه الرئيس بوتين خلال اجتماع موسع
بين الوفدين الروسي الزائر او الصيني
الزائر والروسي تجاري بين بلدينا يتم في
الروبل
بنسبه اثنين الثلثين
محاسبات التي تجري بين روسيا ودول اسيا
وامريكا التينيه وافريقيا فهذا سوف يتطور
ضمن العملات الوطنيه
والدول الاخرى ايضا يمكن ان يتم عبر
اليوان وهناك ايضا
تعاون في بناء الطيران المدني والسفن
وبناء وصناعه السيارات ومستعدون لدعم
الاعمال الصينيه في تعويض الشركات التي
انسحبت من السوق الروسيه
هناك ايضا اهميه بالمنتجات الزراعيه حيث
ازدادت بنسبه
41.4%
بالقيمه وصلت الى سبعه مليارات دولار وهذا
النمو
كان
بنسبه متساويه من قبل الطرفين والوزارات
المختصه تقوم
بالتاكيد على نوعيه المنتجات التي يتم
ايصالها وتوريدها وهذا كله يسمح للنمو
الاضافي
للمنتجات الزراعيه الى اسواق الصينيه
ويمكن ان هذا ان يضمن للامن الغذائي
لبلدينا
واساس استقرار هذا النمو والتطور هو
السياده والاستقلال التقني ونحن نذهب نحو
مسار اكمال
شراكه في
الصناعات المحدده وخاصه فان روسيا والصين
يمكن ان يكون
الدولتان رائدتان في مجال الصناعات
التقنيه والذكاء الاصطناعي ونتيجه
لتعاوننا في المجال
التجاري والاستثمار فهذا يعزز من التطور
العلاقات بين الاقاليم ولذلك كان
الصين شريكا اساسيا في استثمارات في الشرق
الاقصى
وايضا منها المرفا في فلادي ايفوس حيث
يقوم
[موسيقى]
باستثمار في 52
مشروعا بقيمه 10.8 مليار دولار وهناك
شراكه مزدوجه بما في ذلك
في
روسيا الاتحاديه
الاقاليم العمل بين الاقاليم في روسيا
الصين هناك اتفاقيات
ويوجد ايضا بنيه تحتيه للنقل يتم تطويرها
ونحن نعمل على تطوير الخطوط البريه ولذلك
لدينا اولويه في
صياغه او بناء الممرات البريه وسكك الحديد
والتي تمر عبر اراضينا والتي وفقا للطلب
والتهديدات التي تؤثر على النقل
وايضا لقد تم فتح الجسر
وفي نوفمبر تم ايضا فتح جسر لسكك الحديد
وهذا
بتقليص التكاليف لنقل
البضائع بين روسيا والصين ووسعه لجغرافيه
النقل الى بلدان اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
وايضا للعمل على الاستفاده من الممر البحر
الشمالي مع التعاون مع الصين فنحن مستعدون
لتشكيل هيئه مخصصه لتطوير هذا الممر
الشمالي وبعد انتهاء الجائحه فان هناك نمو
للتبادل السياحي والتبادل الثقافي للشباب
في عام 2022 لقد درس في الجامعات الصينيه
6500 الطالب والذي من بينهم الف
كانوا موجودون في الصين ومنهم والباقي
كانوا عن يدرسون عن بعد وهناك يدرس في
روسيا 37
او سبعه الاف طالب من الصين في روسيا
وفقا لتبادل الثقافي للسنه التبادل
الثقافي فهناك اكثر من 100 فعاليه ومنها
ايضا الفعاليات الرياضيه التي اصبحت مهمه
حيث ان الحركه الاولمبيه بدات تبدو مسيسه
ويستخدمون الرياضه كاداه للضغط في الغرب
ولذلك فان دعم تشكيل
رابطات رياضيه ضمن اطار منظمه
وهناك ايضا تعاون في كافه الاتجاهات الذي
سوف يتعزز في المستقبل
لدعم
شعب البلدين والان انقل الكلمه الى ضيفنا
وصديقي الرئيس
الصيني فليتفضل
[موسيقى]
ان نتطور الشراكه
في التجاره والثقافه والاصعاد الدوليه
خلل لقائنا غير رسمي وخلال المباحثات مع
رئيس الوزراء
وخلل المباحثات في الصيغه الضيقه
قمنا بتبادله وجهات النظر حول
مسارات التعاون
وحول مسارات التعسيه التعاوننا
لقد توصلنا الى نتائج ملموسه في
شركتنا ونقوم
بتطوير التعاون
ولقد ذكر الرئيس بوتن
هذه المسائل
يوم الجاري
في الصين مكرس العام الجاري في السن مكرس
اللجنه العشرين والدوره العشرين للجنه حزب
الشيوعيه الصيني في هذا الاطار ان نقوم
بدفع قدوم التحديث
للاليات السنيه ونعمل
تطوير اهدافنا
للشراكه الشامله حتى عام 2003 واقترح
عليكم
التعزيز
قدراتنا للتعاون لكي نستفيد من
الشراكه وحد التعاون والسيد الرئيس ان
استعداد لتحديد خطه
تطوير للعلاقات
الثنائيه وشراكه العمليه اليس على ازدهار
واحيا روسيا والصين وبهذا وصلنا لختم
اذا تابعنا جانبا من هذا الاجتماع الموسع
بين الجانبين الروسي
والصيني تحدث الرئيس بوتين على عدد من
النقاط ربما ابرز ما تحدث عنه بانه
العلاقات بين روسيا وموسكو تدخل حقبه
جديده وايضا قال بان موسكو ستقوم بتامين
كل ما يحتاجه الاقتصاد الصيني على مستوى
الطاقه وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا بالنسبه لبكين
تحدث عن تعاون في كل المجالات المجالات
الصناعيه والزراعيه وايضا حتى فيما يتعلق
بذكاء الاصطناعي وقال بان هناك سيكون
تطوير للخطوط البريه للنقل بين البلدين
لتخفيف تكاليف نقل بضائع وتحدث بوتين عن
تطوير العلاقات ايضا على المستويات
الثقافيه والرياضيه اما الرئيس الصيني
فقال بانه نعمل على تطوير شراكاتنا مع
روسيا في كل المجالات وهذا العام سنقوم
بتطوير الشراكه الشامله حتى العام 2000
وثلاثين على كل حال نتابع نشرتها من
الولايات المتحده حيث تستعد الشرطه في مدن
كبرى لاضطرابات محتمله في حال اعتقال
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامض ضمن تحقيق
بشان مزاعم دفع اموال لممثله اباحيه ابان
الانتخابات عام 2016 وتكذب السلطات في
نيويورك وواشنطن والعاصمه لوس انجلوس من
وجودها تحسبا لاحتجاجات حيث اقيمت
المتاريس والحواجز الفولاذيه خارج محكمه
منهاتن الجنائيه حيث يمكن توجيه الاتهام
الى ترامب
قبل ذلك افادت وكاله بلومبرد بان ترامب لن
يتم تكبيل يديه اذا وجه رسميا الاتهام ضد
في نيويورك ونقلت الوكاله عن مصدر مطلع
قوله بان ترامب من المحتمل ان يظل رهن
الاحتجاز تحت حراسه جهاز سري سيكون مكلف
بحمايته
ووصل مخاوف من اعمال عنف جديده اذا ما تم
اعتقال ترامب يخطط انصار الرئيس السابق
للاحتجاج لكن على طريقتهم الخاصه وهو ما
يعيد للاذهان الهجوم على مبنى الكابيتول
في السادس من يناير 2021 اثرى خساره
الانتخابات الرئاسه امام جو بايدن حيث
اقتحم حينها انصار ترامب مبنى الكونجرس
لكن هذه المره يبدو ان التفكير انصار
ترامب سيكون مختلفا بينما يواجه اتهامات
تتعلق بمدفوعات سريه قدمها لممثله لشراء
صمتها ابانا انتخابات 2016
فبحسب صحيفه فان انصار ترامب يخططون
الاستنزاف المصارف حيث يندفع عدد كبير من
المذيعين لسحب اموالهم من البنوك في وقت
واحد وهو ما قد يؤدي الى ازمه مصرفيه ضخمه
في وقت تعاني فيه البلاد من تبعات ازمه
انهيار مصرف سيليكون ذلك قبل ايام
يستعد المدعي العام لمن هات
لدخول التاريخ كاول مدعي عام يوجه اتهامات
جنائيه لرئيس امريكي سابق
وعلى الرغم من حداثه شغله المنصب الا انه
وجد نفسه في موقف مثير للجدل فبين عشيه
وضحاها تحولت انظار الراي العام اليه بعد
اتهامات ترامب له والتي وصلت حد وصفه
باللبرالي الفوضوي
[تصفيق]
الديمقراطي بالتدخل في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بينما يفتخر مؤيدوه بموقفه حيث
اشادوا بصموده امام هجمات ترامب ادعائيه
وقال احد المحامين الفيدراليين ان براج
البالغ من العمر 49 عاما شخص قوي ليس من
السهل تغيير مبادئه ووفقا للسياسيين فان
براج يواجه مهمه ليست بالسهله
من هارلم بنيويورك حيث امضى طفولته تعرض
لمحاولات اغتيال فاشله ست مرات وفقا لمجله
بوليتيكو
وقبل ان يتقلد منصبه اشرف على دعوه ضد
ترامب اسفرت عن دفع الرئيس السابق غرامه
قدرها مليون دولار
وبعد اكثر من عام من تعيينه اصبحت ترامب
هدفه الجديد
ورغم ان براج استطاع توطيد مكانته الا ان
قضيه ترامب سلطت الاضواء عليه ووضعته امام
اختبار صعب في كيفيه التعامل مع الازمه
هذا وتحولت قضيه ترامب الى معركه سياسيه
قبيل انتخابات العام المقبل فبعد ايام من
الدعاءات بشان اعتقاله خرج غريمه الجمهوري
وحاكم اولاد فلوريدا
عن صمته اخيرا حيث انتقد المدعي العام في
منهات بنيويورك ورغم ان ديسانس المرشح
الجمهوري المحتمل للرئاسه تعهد بان مكتبه
لن يتدخل في تسليم ترامب الى نيويورك الا
انه لم يقدم الدعم وبدلا من ذلك بدا انه
يسخر من الموقف الذي وضع ترامب نفسه فيه
خاصه انه يحاول العوده للحياه السياسيه من
خلال الترشح لانتخابات الرئاسه
عندما انفجر الضحك في مؤتمر صحفي اقيمه في
ولايه فلوريدا انه لا يعرف ما الذي يمكن
ان يحدث في قضيه دفع الاموال لشراء صمت
الممثله الاباحيه واضاف بانه يفضل عدم
الحديث عن ذلك مشيرا الى ان لديه قضايا
وصفها بالحقيقيه للتعامل معها
بدلا من ذلك على كل حال تنضم الينا من
واشنطن هبه القدسي مديره مكتب جريده الشرق
الاوسط في واشنطن لمناقشه هذا الموضوع
استاذه هبه برايك توقيت اثاره هذه القضيه
الان هل تخدم ترامب حقيقه هل ترامب سعيد
بماله اليه الاحداث وتوقيت اثاره هذه
القضيه الان ام انها ستؤثر عليه سلبا
بالتاكيد هناك
لان الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب هو الذي
اثار هذا الموضوع
بتغريده عبر تروس سوشيال اشاره فيها انه
سيتم القبض عليه يوم الثلاثاء وهذا هو
التوقيت حيث تتوقع كافه الدوائر ما يمكن
ان يحدث من ايقاف واعتقال الرئيس ترامب
حسب ما ذكره في هذه الروايه النقطه ان اذا
قارنا على مدى السنوات الماضيه كلما تعرض
الرئيس ترامب
للاتهامات وهناك عدد كثير من التحقيقات
الجنائيه التي تواجه الرئيس ترامبس
بالاحتيال المالي او
بالتدخل في انتخابات جورجيا او هذه القضيه
التي نحن بصدادها الان وبالتالي
يعني في هذه التغريده وايضا بالامس حينما
عرض يعني عبر فيديو يحاول ان يبين ان كل
هذه التهم يزيد تحقيقات هي مجرد مطارده
سياسيه يستغلها الديمقراطيون ضده لمحاكمه
انا اود فقط ان استفيد من وجودك لاسالك
سؤال يعني من محورين السؤال الاول اذا
صدقت توقعات ترامب وتم اعتقاله كيف سيتم
السيطره على هذه الحشود التي
تؤيد ترامبو وسؤال الثاني تداعيات هذا
الامر داخل الحزب الجمهوري كيف سيتصرف هل
سيتخلى عن ترامب هل سيدعم وكيف سيتصرف
ايذاء المرشح الذي سيدعمه
هناك استعدادات امنيه موسعه في واشنطن او
نيويورك او عدد من الدول من المدن
الامريكيه الاخرى بحواجز اسمنتيه وحديديه
وكثير من كاميرات المراقبه لا يبدو ان
هناك
سيكون هناك نوع من الاحتجاجات العنيفه كما
حدث في الهجوم على مبنى كابيت
الدعوات التي خرجت من الرئيس ترامب حرصت
قانونيا على الدعوه للتظاهر وحق التظاهر
مدفون وفق الدستور الامريكي وبالتالي
سيكون هناك ايضا كيف المقرسي دعا الى
الاحتجاج لكن بطريقه سلميه يعني بعيده على
الفوضى ب 20 ثانيه تاثير ذلك داخل حزب
الجمهوري معلش داهمنا الوقت
بالتاكيد هناك مسانده جمهوريه كبيره
للرئيس ترامبو ومحاوله اظهار الامر كانه
يعني نوع من الانتقام السياسي ونوع من
المطارده للرئيس ترامب هناك بعض
من من قبل بعض المرشحين لكن في النهايه
هناك توحد جمهوري وراء الرئيس ترامب انا
اشكرك يا هبه القدسي مديره مكتب جريده
الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن كنت معنا مباشره
العاصمه الامريكيه
صدق الكنيست الاسرائيلي على قانون اقره
عام 2005 يمنح الاسرائيليين حق العوده الى
مستوطنات سابقه تم اخلائها في شمال الضفه
الغربيه في ذات السياق ذكر موقع اسرائيلي
انا الغاء القانون الساري منذ 18 عاما
والذي سمح بالانسحاب من قطاع غزه ومن اربع
مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه سيتيح
للمستوطنين للاقامه في مستوطنات بالضفه
قربه نابلس
الخامسه مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
بسبب قانون التقاعد مواجهات جديده بين
الشرطه الفرنسيه ومحتجين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى فرنسا حيث اندلعت
شبكات بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين بعدما
اجتمعوا في موقع مصفاه النفط سمير التابعه
لشركه اكسون موبايل على احتجاجا على خطط
الحكومه لزياده سن التقاعد واظهرت وسائل
الاعلام فرنسيه مشاهد توثيق لخطه اطلاق
الشرطه الغاز مسيل للدموع على المتظاهرين
وفي محاوله لتهدئه الغضب العمالي يجري
الرئيس الفرنسي
مع جميع الاطراف اليوم غداه تظاهرات
تخللتها توترات حاده في العديد من المدن
الفرنسيه ياتي ذلك بعد ان اقر البرلمان
اعتماد نظام التقاعد الذي لا يبدو انه
سيؤدي الى تهدئه الاحتجاجات قبل ذلك
اعتقلت الشرطه الفرنسيه اكثر من 230 شخص
خلال الاحتجاجات التي جرت يوم امس
تنضم الى باريس زينه علي مراسلت العربيه
زينه اخر المعلومات متعلقه بهذه
الاحتجاجات ورد فعل الحكومه عليها
نعم تحياتي ابراهيم يعني بفارق تسعه اصوات
نجت رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه اليزابيث في
الامس على تصويت لحجب الثقه في البرلمان
الفرنسي لكن هذا الانتصار البرلماني لا
يعني بان المعركه انتهت المعركه بين
الشارع الفرنسي والحكومه الفرنسيه اليوم
كان هناك استنفار على الساحه السياسيه
اجتماعات في قصر الاليزيه وايضا في مقر
رئاسه الوزراء وغدا سيخرج الرئيس ماكرون
ليخاطب الشعب الفرنسي ويحاول تهدئته بعد
هذه الاحتجاجات العارمه ايضا على الارض
يحتشد المتظاهرون ويخرجون بمظاهرات عفويه
غير منظمه يقطعون الطرق وايضا هناك قطع في
المواصلات وفي توزيع الوقود ايضا يعني
الحركه في الارض ما زالت في غليان مستمر
الشارع الفرنسي ايضا
دعوات الى الاستفتاء على استفتاء شعبي هذا
الاسم لكن رد فعل الشارع الفرنسي على ما
يحدث المواطن الفرنسي ربما هو المتضرر
الاول الان نتيجه هذه الاحتجاجات وقطع
الطرق والمواصلات وترك النفايات لو تجمل
لنا بدقيقه رد الفعل الفرنسي
الذين يؤيدون الحركات الاحتجاجيه هم
متعصبون لهذه الحركه ويرون ان نتيجه تدهور
الوضع في في الارض هي بسبب الحكومه
الفرنسيه
ويحملون الحكومه الفرنسيه جميع طبعات ذلك
لكن ايضا هناك فئه رغم تعاطفها مع حركه
الشارع لكنها ترى بان هناك يعني حاله من
يعني تصعيد غير المبرر خاصه في مساله
النفايات وايضا في مساله قطع الطرقات
والمواصلات شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات زينه علي مراسله العربيه كنت
معنا من باريس
في افغانستان اعيد فتح المدارس للعام
الدراسي الجديد لكن بدون فصول دراسيه حيث
ماتت المدارس خاليه من التلاميذ او
بالاحرى من التلميذات بسبب القيود التي
تفرضها طالبان على تعليمهن هي قود عزلت
النساء من الحياه بشكل عام ومنعت الفتيات
من الذهاب او الذهاب الى المدارس ومنذ
اغسطس اب من العام 2021 تفرض طالبان قيودا
واسعه على النساء من بينها منع تعليم
الفتيات في المدارس الثانويه لتبقى
افغانستان الدوله الوحيده في العالم التي
يحذر فيها على الفتيات الذهاب الى المدرسه
الثانويه ففي اليوم الاول للدراسه وعكس
المتوقع باتت الفصول خاويه ولم يحضر سوى
عدد قليل من المعلمين وطلاب المراحل
الابتدائيه
[موسيقى]
وزير التعليم في حكومه طالبان اصر على
موقف الحركه من تعليم الفتيات وقال الوزير
في بيان انه لا عوده للفتيات الى المدارس
المتوسطه والثانويه مضيفا انا التعليم
الفتيات مسموح به فقط لمن هم في المرحله
الابتدائيه
بعد دعوه من المحكمه العليا في السعوديه
يستعد عامه المسلمين في انحاء البلاد
اليوم التي الى تحري رؤيه هلال شهر رمضان
ودعت المحكمه العليا في السعوديه ايضا ممن
يرى هلال رمضان بالعين المجرده او بواسطه
المناظير ابلاغ اقرب محكمه اليه وتسجيل
شهادته اليها او الاتصال باقرب مركز
لمساعدته في الوصول الى اقرب محكمه
وانضم الينا مرصد مير شمال غرب الرياض
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز اهلا بك نواف اذا
متى ستبدا عمليه رصد هلال رمضان ولماذا
مرصد اثنين يتم التركيز عليه تحديدا
اهلا ابراهيم نعم اقل من نصف ساعه متبقيه
على مغيب الشمس هنا في مرصد تمير شمال
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض هذا المرصد
ابراهيم هو واحد من عشر مراصد في السعوديه
معتمده لدى المحكمه العليا يعتمد ربما
كثيرا على هذا المرصد وتتجه الانظار له
نظرا لموعد غروب الشمس مبكرا مقارنه ببقيه
المراصد وعلى الرغم من تقارب المواعيد الا
ان هذا المرصد سيكون من المراصد الاولى
التي يغيب فيها تغيب فيها الشمس هنا كما
نشاهد في هذه الصوره التلسكوب من مدينه
الملك عبد العزيز للعلوم والتقنيه
بالاضافه الى المترائين المنتدبين حكوميا
والذين يعملون على رؤيه هلال شهر رمضان
عين المجرده وتقديم الشهادات لمندوبي
المحكمه العليا سواء بتقديم الشهادات
لرؤيه الهلال او عدم رؤيه هلال رمضان هنا
نشاهد تقنيه جديده من وزاره العدل
السعوديه وهي تقنيه تربط جميع مراصد
السعوديه العشر بالمحكمه العليا عبر
الاتصال المرئي لتسريع عمليه تقديم
الشهادات برؤيه الهلال من عدمه وايضا لرفع
كفاءه العمل حول رصد الاهله هنا ايضا
التواجد في هذا المرصد يتواجد مترائين
عملوا في هذا المرصد لسنوات طويله ربما 15
عاما ومن خلال هذا المرصد سيتم الاعلان
يعني بشكل رسمي من قبل المترائين هنا
برؤيه الهلال من عدمه وتقديم الشهاده
للمحكمه العليا ومن ثم ترفع من المحكمه
العليا الى الملك سلمان ويصدر البيان
الرسمي سواء بان يكون غدا هو اول ايام شهر
رمضان او هو المتمم لشهر شعبان والخميس هو
اول ايام شهر رمضان المبارك على كل حال
المراصد ستقدم الشهادات بالترائي وايضا
اتباعا ياتي هذا بالاضافه الى اخر المراصد
في السعوديه وهو مرصد منطقه تبوك الذي
تمس ربما بعد ساعه من الان ستنتظر المحكمه
العليا اكتمال
بالتاكيد يعني خلال الساعه القادمه انا
اشكرك نواف عزيز مراسل العربيه كنت ميرسي
الغربي الرياض وكل عام وانت بالف خير نصل
مشاهدين
الخامسه كل عام وانتم بالف خير ورمضان
مبارك سعيد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]